[Musik]
phoenix runde ja schon guten abend und
herzlich willkommen aus berlin
auch hier schaut die politik natürlich
gespannt auf den 26 auf die wahl der
jetzt schon als europäische
schicksalswahl gilt wir werden über
diese debatte diskutieren und mal uns
fragen wer wäre denn vielleicht der
bessere kommissionspräsident wenn
überhaupt einer von diesen es wird das
sind unsere gäste professor hans werner
sinn ist bei uns ehemaliger direktor des
wirtschaftsinstituts er befürchtet
angesichts des brh exits das scheitern
der eben professor christine re
politologin der hertie school of
governance professorin für europäische
politik und sie war sowohl in london als
auch in brügge tätig ich begrüße eric
bonse freier korrespondent in brüssel er
betreibt den blog lost in europe und
ewald könig ist bei uns freier
journalist und jahre lang chefredakteur
und herausgeber des nachrichtenportals
euractiv sechs personen haben das
diskutiert es war ein bisschen schwierig
mit all den sprachen war dass so ein
bild wo man sieht ja europa ist auch
kompliziert und die kommunikation in
europa ist auch manchmal nicht so
einfach
ja allerdings es war zum teil schwierig
der debatte zu folgen
das lag natürlich an diesem
sprachproblemen ist zum teil natürlich
auch etwas absurd wenn deutsche
teilnehmer auf englisch übersetzt werden
und dann wieder zurück übersetzt werden
beziehungsweise englisch sprechen müssen
und dann zurückgesetzt werden
da geht dann auch einiges verloren was
mir aber vor allem aufgefallen ist es
war eine ungleiche debatte wir hatten
drei kandidaten die die wirkliche
spitzenkandidaten sind in
anführungszeichen dieser beruf muss und
diskutiert werden
das heißt der herr weber die frau
vestager und der zimmermanns könnten
tatsächlich kommissionspräsident werden
die anderen drei realistischerweise
nicht die können nur koalitionen
eingehen und das ist schon eine krux bei
diese diskussion und dann fehlte
natürlich sozusagen der elefant im raum
die rechtspopulisten die eu-gegner die
kritiker waren sich die waren deshalb
müssen wir das auch direkt mal erklären
weil es dort keinen spitzenkandidaten
gibt von dieser gruppe das macht eben
auch noch einmal komplizierter da könig
was war ihr eindruck haben sie wissen
sie jetzt mehr wer für welches europa
steht also ich fand die ganze debatte
streckenweise ein bisschen gruselig
inhaltlich habe ich sehr viel gehört von
wir wollen wir müssen wir brauchen und
da fällt einem bein biss ihr habt ihr
nicht längst
und was mich in berlin von wo wir senden
aufregt also die straßen sind gesäumt
von laternen plakaten mit gesichtern die
kaum jemand kennt und mit völlig
nichtssagenden slogans und sehr viel
anders war diese debatte auch nicht das
waren viele leere worthülsen die sekunde
nur die im hintergrund immer gelaufen
ist hat er gezeigt man kann er keine
gedanken wirklich richtig aussprechen
und ich habe das gefühl dass diese
debatte die entfernung von vielen
bürgern nach brüssel noch vergrößert hat
ok herr sehen würde ist auch eigentlich
negativ sehen oder gibts was wo sie
sagen das hat mir heute abend doch
normal dass klar gemacht wer für welches
europa steht das ist natürlich nicht
aber es war ein happening und der
vorteil war dass man diese personen mal
persönlich erlebt hat was sonst ja nicht
der fall ist
das fand ich jetzt für mich genommen
ganz interessant konnte also diese
persönlichkeiten ein bisschen erahnen
und die drei haupt spitzenkandidaten
machten tatsächlich alle eine recht gute
figur
was man inhaltlich sagen kann das sind
ja nur plattitüden das geht ja nicht zur
sache und noch eines zu der zu den
spitzenkandidaten überhaupt natürlich
der nachteil ist dass der elefant gar
nicht dabei war
er kann man sagen wir stricken das so
mit den spitzenkandidaten dass die dann
eben nicht da sind weil sie keinen haben
aber das hätte man ja auch anders machen
können
das fehlte ihm und auch immer noch ein
weiterer elefant einer der ein möglicher
spitzenkandidat ist und gute chancen
hätte ist michel barnier der aber seine
kandidatur noch nicht erklärt hat und
daher auch nicht mitgemacht hat also das
ist auch ein bisschen einer verzerrung
kann man gleich auch noch mal zur frage
was war ihr eindruck vom einlegen
was ich interessant war dass man bei den
spitzenkandidaten schon gesehen hat
welche rolle sie auch im moment
ausfüllen ich fand dass die beiden
kommissare schon sehr viel stärker auf
europäische solidarität europäische
problemlösung lösungen wirklich schon
von fragen die die bürger bewegen
natürlich in worthülsen und dass die
abgeordnete vestager und franz thema
richtig wichtig und dass die
abgeordneten doch stärker ziehen
sie ihren bei kreisen gesprochen haben
sie ihren ländern sehr viel stärker auch
die zusammenarbeit mit den
mitgliedstaaten betont haben schon daran
hat man schon absehen können sozusagen
ja auch die rolle der kommission und des
europaparlaments im europäischen
institutionen gefüge aber die ein
kleines bisschen nicht gefährlich findet
an der debatte ist aber der
kommissionspräsident
die kommissionspräsidentin sind ja nur
sagen ein resultat dieser dieser wahl
das ist ja ein ganzes bündel von
konsequenzen die uns dann nach der
europawahl ins haus stehen wir haben es
natürlich heute sehr stark auf eine
institution fokussiert wir müssen uns
immer im zusammenspiel der drei
institutionen rat kommission und
parlament sehen aber das ist ja auch das
problem dass viele leute auch sagen dass
sie gar nicht richtig verstehen wie
europa funktioniert nach wie vor als wir
haben eine starke europawahl
berichterstattung jetzt aber 49 prozent
sagen ich verstehe nicht ganz was da in
europa passiert herr bonse fokussieren
wir uns deshalb jetzt im moment so auf
die köpfe weil wir obwohl europa ja
eigentlich viel mehr ist als jetzt
einzelne köpfe ist das ein grund
na ja das ist natürlich ein versuch
europa verständlich zu machen europa
lebendig zu machen europa zu
personifizieren was auch dringend nötig
ist das fehlt natürlich schon diesen
sehr anonymen und komplexen strukturen
an brüssel wo ich jetzt gerade herkomme
es gibt aber natürlich doch immer noch
ein problem mit diesen spitzenkandidaten
auch in dieser sendung das muss man sich
glaube ich ganz klar noch mal sagen
diese europawahl ist keine direktwahl es
ist keine direktwahl eines
kommissionspräsidenten dieses ist nicht
die französische präsidentschaftswahl
und dieses ist auch nicht die
bundestagswahl sozusagen indirekt dann
eine kanzlerin kanzler gewählt wird es
wird erst einmal ein neues parlament
gewählt
in den einzelnen ländern nach nationalen
listen das ist ja auch eine krux die ich
auch immer wieder kritisieren
ich habe meinen wahlzettel jetzt
bekommen für die briefwahl in brüssel
aus nordrhein westfalen wo ich herkomme
da taucht kein herr zimmermann es auch
da taucht kein herr weber auf ich kann
beide nicht wählen
und insofern ist diese inkarnation
natürlich auch widersprüchlich wir
machen debatten um die leute zu sehen
und sie kennen zu lernen dafür war
sicherlich auch hilfreich war auch ganz
lebendig aber am ende können wir sie
nicht wählen und wie diese
spitzenkandidaten sich möglicherweise
dann umsetzen lassen in der neuen
kommissionspräsidenten und andere top
jobs das wissen wir noch gar
darüber entscheiden nämlich andere
staats und regierungschefs frau merkel
herr mack und andere das was wir gesehen
haben also für die parteien stehen was
wir natürlich aber im blick behalten
müssen dass die kommission ein neutrales
organ sein soll eigentlich kein
parteipolitisches sorgen für das
supranationale interesse eintreten soll
ich bin das ist auch ein bisschen ein
problem oder eine eine krux an den
spitzenkandidaten debatten potenzial
wird niemand der kandidaten
kommissionspräsident und selbst wenn er
oder sie kommissionspräsident werden
dass eine große koalition aus 27 28
parteien nationalen interessen werden
und niemand wird ein programm
durchsetzen können komplex natürlich
komplex kompliziert ist es ein
konstruktionsfehler herr könig dass
allein die frage also komplexität der
europäischen und da kann man sehr viel
diskutieren aber allein die frage an die
kandidaten was würden sie als
kommissionspräsident tun die können ja
gar nicht dass alles tun was sich
irgendwie da versprochen haben und
ansonsten zur ursprünglichen frage
natürlich ist die europäische union
reformbedürftig und zu kompliziert
schwer zu verstehen
obwohl es schon eine holschuld oder eine
bringschuld sozusagen ist von vielen
bürgern um müssen sie hat mehr zeitung
lesen oder blogs von eric bonse oder
jetzt schon sehr viele informationen
aber allein die bezeichnungen dass zb
sehr vieles rat heißt und ich würde
wetten wenn wir auf der straße fragen
was ist der unterschied zwischen
europarat und dem europäischen rat ja
werden viele unsicher seien
und warum würden sie sagen findet man
das ja der europarat ist ein großes
gremium mit vielen auch ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken und der europäische rat
ist das gipfeltreffen der staats und
regierungschefs und meister
das höchste gremium der europäischen und
aber auch viele andere dinge vielleicht
müsste man nachdenken ob man da andere
bezeichnungen finden kann die besser
selbsterklärend sind und
was anfangen kann also das ist sozusagen
die art wie darüber geredet wird
margrethe vestager hat ja auch gesagt
man muss auch selbstkritisch sein wie
wir reden und mit welchen begriffen herr
sind begibt und punkt wo sie sagen da da
wünsche ich mir wirklich eine andere art
wie auch über über europa und wie europa
kommuniziert ärgert sind das dinge die
sie ärgern
ja natürlich sie hat gesagt man sollte
ich diese ganzen abkürzung nehmen und
die dinge aussprechen
das ist so eine marginalie
es ist in der tat sehr schwer zu
verstehen wer versteht europa schon dass
das geht über die köpfe der leute hinweg
da ist ein apparat entstanden der wird
immer komplexer mit macht zusammenhängen
und wirkung ska neelen die kein mensch
durchschaut und dann ist ja vor allem
neben diesen offiziellen gremien dieser
riesige lobby apparat darf nicht also
gehen sogar brüssel da sehen sie alle
branchen europas die firmen alle sind
sie vertreten weil sie wissen da müssen
sie einfluss nehmen auf ihre
abgeordneten und das läuft dann jenseits
des demokratischen prozesses das ist ein
gestrüpp und ein wirrwarr geworden wobei
es nicht in jeder hinsicht zufrieden
stellt also da haben wir auch ein
demokratiedefizit
man sollte klarere strukturen schaffen
joschka fischer hat ja schon mal früher
eine große reform angedacht für europa
das hätte man vielleicht mal aufgreifen
sollen aber so wie das jetzt
strukturiert ist weiß man gar nicht wo
die machtzentren liegen und wie die
entscheidungs kanäle eigentlich wirklich
laufen ja ich wollte anfügen weil der
große widerspruch die zahl der
hauptberuflich tätigen lobbyisten steigt
aber die zahl der akkreditierten
korrespondenten in brüssel sinkt jene
journalisten durch das alles erklären
und kontrollieren sollten
das finde ich schon bitter klingt es
ziemlich negativ erst mal in der ersten
runde
wenn es wirklich so komplex wir haben
die europäische kommission die das
europäische interesse vertritt wir haben
den europäischen rat und den rat der die
nationalen regierungen und die staats
und regierungschefs vertreten und wir
haben das europäische parlament das die
bevölkerung europas vertritt beim 828
bald 27 länder wir haben ganz viele
nationale tradition wir haben ganz viele
verfassen traditionen und interessen es
muss ja komplex seien
in dem moment wo es nicht komplex wäre
würde es vielleicht besser verstanden
aber könnte man diesen ganz vielen
verschiedenen interessen die
ausgeglichen und wo man kompromisse
finden muss einfach nicht rechnung dran
und man muss natürlich auch sagen ein
teil der vielen lobbyisten ist einfach
dort weil die kommission so klein es für
die vielen aufgaben die sie hat die
lobby ist natürlich sind sie da aber sie
beraten auch die kommission aus ganz
verschiedenen aus ganz verschiedenen
richtungen es gibt transparenz vorstöße
und auch erfolgreiche vorstöße die
lobbyarbeit in brüssel stärker zu
regulieren
sehr viel stärker als als in manch einem
nationalen systemen
ich denke die komplexität ist einfach
ausdruck davon dass wir verstehen müssen
und kompromisse finden müssen in europa
das kann kein einfaches ist also was ich
besonders würde ich sagen doch kritik
würde ich finde ist die art wie dieser
der europäische rat funktioniert das ist
ja praktisch auf der zunächst einmal der
ministerrat aber wenn die
regierungschefs sich treffen ist es der
europäische rat und der ministerrat
denkmals so ein gremium wo also eine
bestimmte zahl von leuten drin sitzen
die die länder repräsentieren
pustekuchen ist gar nicht der fall
es gibt ganz viele minister rede je nach
fachgebiet ja da treffen sich jeweils
die fachminister untereinander unter
juristen die das besser verstehen als
ich habe mal von der umkehrung der
demokratie gesprochen zum beispiel
umweltpolitik da sind ist also zu hause
ein engagierter umweltpolitiker der will
radikale maßnahmen durchsetzen die dem
regierungschef aber zu radikal sind und
da kommt also zu hause gar nicht durch
ja was macht er geht nach brüssel trifft
sich mit den anderen umweltministern
bilden ministerrat und wir sind alle
einer meinung so und so muss man das
machen und schon kommt der beschluss
zustande
und dann müssen zum schluss die
nationalen parlamente irgendeine
richtlinie exekutieren die auf diese
weise
beschlossen wurde natürlich das
europäische parlament muss ja auch noch
zustimmen ist schon richtig aber es ist
ein stückchen umkehrung der demokratie
wo die nationalen parlamente zu
erfüllungsgehilfen werden und da ist
schon das system verbesserungsfähig
sagen wir mal wir brauchen ja europa und
wir brauchen aber ein klareres da würden
wir strukturieren euro wurden sie dann
sagen das war ja auch eine position von
herrn von nielsen vertreter also sehr
agil der sagte er will da weniger europa
apple mehr kompetenz bei den über den
nationalstaaten das würden ja gar nicht
mal mehr oder weniger das ist jetzt ein
anderes thema sondern ist die frage der
entscheidungsfindung das ist aber auch
richtig wir haben ja das
subsidiaritätsprinzip das ist auf
deutschen wunsch in den maastrichter
vertrag reingekommen wonach eine
entscheidung möglichst auf einer
untergeordneten gebietskörperschaft
ebene getroffen werden muss und nur wenn
es gar nicht anders geht weil es
grenzüberschreitende extern ali täten
gibt in europa nehmen sie mal das thema
stäube die da also von den autos
abgesondert werden das zum diesen
fahrverbot führt und so weiter da sagt
man das ist jetzt euro europa die
europäer haben eine richtlinie gemacht
die müssen wir umsetzen
aber was ist denn hier eigentlich
europäisch daran ob es in stuttgart zu
viel
stickoxide in der stadt gibt das ist
doch eine stuttgarter angelegenheit ist
kann man den grenzüberschreitenden
ich mache das ist ihre sache
vielleicht da auch unterbrechen und
aufzuklären also das ist ja doch schon
eine eindeutige kompetenz dann der eu
des europaparlaments dass die grenzwerte
mit diskutiert und auch mitbestimmt die
umsetzung und die messung vor ort das
ist dann wieder eine nationale lokale
kompetenz und das kann man relativ klar
auseinander halten
ja denn ich wollte auch gemacht aber das
ist in sich bereits eine verletzung des
subsidiaritätsprinzips das überhaupt
europa sich dieser sache annimmt
umwelt- und klimapolitik hat eben wenn
wir das wäre klimapolitik ist
grenzüberschreitend europäische
außenpolitik ist grenzüberschreitend
alles mögliche gibt es wichtige
europäische themen sind aber nun nicht
gerade die lokalen städtischen
stickoxide
nein aber wenn ihr keine gemeinsamen
grenzwerte für diese fahrzeuge hätten
wäre es problematisch deutsche
diesel-fahrzeuge nach frankreich zu
verkaufen oder nach portugal
die städtische emission nicht um die
emissionshandels einheit nicht geredet
aber ich wollte noch einmal ganz kurz
versuchen im sinne auch von frau eine
lanze für brüssel und für die kommission
zu brechen so kompliziert ist es dann
auch widerlich letzten endes die
kommission soll im grunde genommen die
interessen aller 28 mitgliedsstaaten
waren und gesetze vorschlagen so ist es
in den verträgen geregelt und wir
erleben jetzt einen machtkampf zwischen
der kommission dem rat und dem parlament
das europaparlament sagt jetzt wir
wollen mehr macht wir sind hier einzig
demokratisch legitimierten hier in
brüssel
wir wollen jetzt den
kommissionspräsidenten wir stellen und
da habt ihr uns zu folgen und der rat
widersetzt sich dem und sagt nein es
gibt keinen automatismus wer der herr
weber noch der herr timmermanns
noch-frau westergaard selbst wenn die
die meisten stimmen bekommen sollten
werden automatisch eingesetzt zum
kommissionspräsident dass ein machtkampf
den wir erleben diesen machtkampf ist
öffentlichkeit wichtig und funktional
der machtkampf
das ist die frage und das ist das jetzt
wieder die crux auf unserer debatte denn
zwei tage nach der europawahl werden
sich die staats und regierungschefs frau
merkel und alle anderen in brüssel
treffen um dann das weitere prozedere zu
klären und da ist ein problem natürlich
auch in unseren demokratischen
machtkampf wer setzt sich denn da
eigentlich durch das heißt wir gehen zur
wahl in der wissen gar nicht wer am ende
sich von diesen spitzenkandidaten
überhaupt durchsetzen kann
die meisten stimmen bekommen was würden
sie denken was was würden sie nur dem
wähler den rat also das ist ja dann die
frage wenn ich da zur wahl gehe will ich
doch eigentlich auch wissen wer wem ich
mit meiner stimme sozusagen ins amt
helfen befinden uns da in einem
zwischenstadium also wir haben ja die
gespräche schon an beispielen gehört ich
kann das selber auch nur bestätigen
also wenn ich jetzt aus als österreicher
bin in deutschland und ich bekomme von
österreich als briefwähler viele namen
von dem man fast alle nicht kennt wenn
man nicht in wien lebt ja dann hat das
relativ wenig sinn solcher namen
anzukreuzen
also musste ich drauf stehen wir
sinnvoll aber die werden ja dann doch
wiederum nicht die lösung jetzt nicht
verraten sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich
ganz reich mit einem guten berater 100
aber der jetzige zustand ist auf jeden
fall unbefriedigend trotzdem ist eher
der versuch gestartet also gerade mit
den spitzenkandidaten zu sagen wir
wollen europa ja mehr personifizieren
frau welchen von den kandidaten macht
ihrer meinung nach denn dort so den
überzeugendsten eindruck wir haben wir
dann frans timmermans der erste vize
kommissionspräsident waren haben wir
frau festtage wettbewerbskommissarin dem
sind eben schon im amt er weber der
schon lange in brüssel ist also wenn man
denkt die drei haben eine chance
wie groß ist denn die wirklich die
chance von denen jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz auf dem prozess ein zugehen der
vertrag ist ja sehr ausbalanciert
die staats und regierungschefs schlagen
vor die wahl im blick haltend und das
parlament bestätigt oder oder eben nicht
ich fand dass das alle dass alle drei
kandidaten sich im rahmen dessen was
möglich ist in grenzen der europäischen
öffentlichkeit gut geschlagen haben
ich denke frau becker hat einen sehr
guten eindruck gemacht als das liberale
system hoch halten aber gleichzeitig für
fairen wettbewerb und faire besteuerung
einzutreten und sie hat uns als
wettbewerbskommissarin ja schon gezeigt
das möglich ist es ja die tech giganten
angegangen in dieser rolle
das heißt was mich bei ihr überzeugt hat
ist sie hat wirklich über die themen
gesprochen in denen die kommission eine
ganz ganz starke rolle spielt im bereich
außenpolitik spielt die kommission eine
absolut untergeordnete rolle im bereich
sozialpolitik gut juncker hat eine
relativ soziale soziale kommission
geführt
aber ich habe sie ist wirklich auf das
auf das kerngebiet der europäer
eingegangen der europäischen kommission
eingegangen in einer frage die die
europäer bewegt fähre faire besteuerung
in dem gefragt was man den wählern raten
sollte ich glaube es ganz wichtig ist
für die wähler ist im blick zu behalten
was das europäische parlament eigentlich
tut das europäische parlament die
zentrale rolle ist der
gesetzgebungsprozess und natürlich
fragen an die kommission aber vor allem
das des gesetzgebungs das
gesetzgebungsverfahren und das sind
fragen die die bürger und bürgerinnen
bewegen konsum lebensmittelsicherheit
wettbewerb etc
was ist europäische parlament aber
eigentlich nicht tut ist die großen
entscheidungen zu europas zukunft zu
treffen
das tun die staats und regierungschefs
und das spielt sich auf den
mitgliedstaaten ab also ein vielleicht
eine rat an die opfer wählt die
abgeordneten oder den kandidaten den
wenn ich wählen können aber im geiste
mit der politik geliefert
die ihr gut findet und nicht nur
aufgrund von pro antieuropäischen
haltung denn die werden nicht im
parlament entschieden hätten aus sicht
des ökonomen gibt es eigentlich einen
großen unterschied zu wenig von dem
sagen wir mal diese drei dinge chance
haben und vielleicht noch michel barnier
den bereich sind immer komm jetzt ins
spiel gebracht hat wenig da wählen wer
das rennen macht also wir haben ja vor
augen eigentlich den großen konflikt mit
den amerikaner
das kam ja in der debatte auch dran
die amerikaner verlangen dass die
europäer ihre agrarmärkte öffnen die
sind nämlich nicht offen die sind sehr
geschlossen mit allen möglichen nicht
tarif ehren handelshemmnissen und
da spitzt sich ein konflikt zu zwischen
frankreich und deutschland
der tramp sagt macht eure märkte auch
für unsere agrarprodukte und wenn er das
nicht macht dann lassen wir eure autos
nicht mehr rein
können sie sich vorstellen was frau
merkel dazu sagt und hermagor dazu sagt
also marco sagt unter keinen umständen
wir müssen jetzt den bösen amerikanern
hier pardon geben und einen handelskrieg
eingehen und ihnen mal zeigen wo es lang
geht und dass dann die deutschen autos
nicht mehr verkauft werden können das
nimmt ja so als kollateralschaden hin
und die merkel denkt sich natürlich das
können wir nicht machen wir müssen die
schützen sollen lieber eingehen auf den
trump und die agrarmärkte aufmachen
also das war so ein bisschen im
hintergrund es haben sich hier viel in
der debatte für fairen handel
ausgesprochen das hört sich ja gut an
das sind ja aber nur vokabeln fairer
handel ist eigentlich ein anderer
ausdruck für protektionismus sagt ja
keiner es für protektionisten für fairen
handel wenn ihr eure eure händchen damit
chlorwasser wasch dann dürfte die nicht
liefern das ist er nicht fair oder sowas
oder genmanipuliert in wahrheit ist sind
dass handelsbeschränkungen und da fand
ich jetzt weber am überzeugendsten
jedenfalls aus deutscher sicht und auch
glaube ich aus gesamteuropäischer sicht
in dem er da ein plädoyer dafür gegeben
hat dass europa handels offen bleibt
also was wäre denn aus europa wenn wir
uns abschotten würden um mit mit der
idee des fairen handels alles mögliche
verbieten was im ausland produziert wird
weil es dieses oder jenes oder selbiges
kriterium nicht erfüllt
das ist ja eine unglückliche entwicklung
ja sie haben vorher bonse von dem
elefant im raum gesprochen der eine
waren sind die rechts verrissen ja was
anderes der exit der irgendwo wochen
beschäftigt hat und im moment ja die
briten nehmen teil an der europawahl
was bedeutet das eigentlich also wenn
man ja das heißt das dann überhaupt für
uns jetzt wie wir damit weiter umgehen
und was bedeutet das wenn wir jetzt die
briten wenn die mit wählen und dann aber
wir nicht wissen wie es da weitergeht
das bedeutet im grunde genommen erst mal
dass wir ein parlament wählen dass
möglicherweise
ein nicht sehr großes haltbarkeitsdatum
hat also die britischen abgeordneten
sich möglicherweise abgeordnete auf zeit
selbst das ist allerdings auch wieder
umstritten der eine oder andere sagt in
brüssel ein abgeordneter ist also ein
vertreter der europäisch des
europäischen parlamentes und im namen
des der europäischen union gewählt und
bleibt auch dann mitglied des
parlamentes wenn das land austritt
andere haben die gegenteilige meinung
das heißt wir wissen nicht ob
möglicherweise im herbst die britischen
abgeordneter ausscheiden dass das eine
das andere ist was wir wissen ist dass
die konservativen ein problem bekommen
also die tories in großbritannien
schmieren gerade in umfragen ab und sie
sind in europa parlament nicht in einer
großen fraktion vertreten
das heißt sie können also weder herrn
weber stärken in der europäischen
volkspartei weil es da keine
fraktionsgemeinschaft gibt noch jemand
anders wissens jansa hradil da haben sie
ein bisher zusammengearbeitet
während die sozialdemokraten das relativ
entspannt sehen die profitieren nämlich
von der labour abgeordnete kommen und
auch die grünliberalen freuen sich die
grünen bekommen ein wenig auf die
liberalen bekommen sich nicht auf wenn
das macht das ganze aber zu einem
taktischen spielchen das europaparlament
wird teil eines taktischen spielchen zum
den exit weil die reinen profitieren die
andere profitieren nicht wir haben aber
immer noch keine gewissheit wie gesagt
wie lange kann dieses parlament in
dieser konstellation mit 28 ländern
arbeiten werden die britischen
abgeordneten möglicherweise auch den
kommissionspräsidenten mitbestimmen
dürfen was ja ziemlich bizarr werden die
black city kollegen von der wechsel
party dann nur stunk machen und nur
fensterreden halten gegen europa für
rage ist ja da ein bewährter demagoge
also all das wissen wir nicht und ich
muss sagen ich finde es richtig schwach
vom parlament dass ich dazu auch nicht
äußert es nimmt das so hin das ist also
eine situation die am rande einer farce
ist
man hätte den exit entweder vorher
klären müssen
oder man hätte zum beispiel in den
vertrag auch rein schreiben können das
land das den austritt aus der
europäischen union beantragt kann nicht
mehr in europa wahlen teilnehmen dieses
jahr eine logische konsequenz immer
wieder dritten aspekt anfügen
die europawahl könnte auch ein gewisses
signal geben wenn die wahlbeteiligung in
großbritannien groß ist hat das den
charakter eines zweiten referendums dann
wird man sich auch noch viel gedanken
machen müssen
und wenn ich den text verwenden darf um
auf außenpolitik zu kommen weil die
briten immer sehr gut in außenpolitik
waren und auch eine eine sehr berühmte
diplomatie hatten also jetzt in die
debatte ist diese diplomatisch vor dem
versagen aber nicht nur in der
europäischen union ist die außenpolitik
unter geordnet wie flora schon sagte
sondern auch in dieser debatte ist die
aussenpolitik untergeordnet gewesen und
da muss ich dem kandidaten weber recht
geben wir brauchen dringend ein
mehrheitsprinzip und nicht an
einstimmigkeitsprinzip also europa ist
momentan so verzwickt wir haben hier
trump wir haben putin wir haben china
wir haben westbalkan die die länder
wollen in die europäische union
eintreten in nordafrika und im
arabischen raum
kriselt es überall und europa hat nichts
zu sagen kann ist dass viel
selbstbewusster auftreten müsste
selbstbewusster auftreten daher ist die
einstimmigkeit ein problem bei den
kompromiss so schwer sind und warum das
so ist warum wir eine high repräsentativ
haben und nicht eine richtige
außenministerin die außenbeauftragte
wie genau die außenbeauftragte wobei
frau margarine also nicht viel anders
als die vorgängerin fröschen also ein
bisschen glück los ist aber ich muss
sagen da das ist die schulter briten die
also auf jeden fall vermeiden wollten
dass die europäische union stark ist und
außenpolitik und damit kompetenzen der
briten wegnehmen kann wie sehr schlecht
der praxis die eu fror i und ii kann
was macht jetzt sinn nach der europawahl
wie die sollte man damit dann umgehend
ich finde noch eine sache sagen zu den
73 mitgliedern des europaparlaments die
briten wählen werden wir sehen uns im
moment ganz stark aus der sicht der anti
europäer
wir haben unsere augen auf der wechsel
party aber die briten wäre natürlich
auch sehr pro europäische abgeordnete
schicken über labour über die grünen
über change uk und potenziell eine
relativ große ein großes kontingent von
labour abgeordneten die die
sozialdemokraten stärken werden
ich denke dass der unterschied der wahl
sich eher auf der pro-europäischen und
auf der linken seite zeigt als bei den
anti europäer da bekommen wir ohnehin
einen sehr starken einen sehr starken
block ich denke dass der exit an sich
gezeigt dass die 27 zusammenhalten
können wenn es um fragen des
binnenmarktes geht wenn es um fragen von
freizügigkeit geht wenn es um gemeinsame
wenn es um wenn es um gemeinsame
verhandlungen geht man muss allerdings
auch sagen moment geht es ja immer noch
nur um das historische grämen wenn man
noch überhaupt nicht angefangen mit der
diskussion der künftigen verhältnis
zwischen großbritannien und der eu und
in dem moment werden potenziell die
unterschiede
wo kommt ich denke zwei dinge wo würden
sie doch hoffen dass der break sind doch
noch rückgängig gemacht wird schwer
schwer schwer vorstellbar gleichzeitig
schwer vorstellbar dass das streamen
durch das britische parlament geht
schwer vorstellbar dass die europäische
union sagt wir vollziehen hinwegsieht
obwohl das britische parlament sagt wir
wollen ohne deal nicht gehen sagen
frostig special ist nicht erlaubt unter
den verträgen ist ein ganz ganz komplexe
situation
ich glaube dass die eu durch geschwächt
wurde was die urban meines erachtens
völlig verpasst hat ist ein brett als
chance zu reformen zu nehmen zu sagen es
gibt dieses land was geht was heißt es
für uns heißt es nicht nur dass leute
gehen wollen ja eigentlich sind wo sehen
sie denn oder wo wäre eine chance
gewesen sagen wir die eu das anders
wahrgenommen hätte dann hätten wir
richtige exit nicht gehabt und wir
hätten auch mit rechnet der reform also
wer hat da er hat er geschlafen
naja also musik ist es echt nicht
bewusst verhindert sie nicht die chance
wenn die briten draußen sind das wäre
dann die eu endlich mal so reformieren
können wie
wie es die briten verhindert haben also
gott bewahre denn die briten haben für
weil begriffe mit ihrer weltoffenen
freihandels orientierten grund
positionierung deutschland sehr geholfen
unter dem schutz der briten hat sich die
deutsche exportindustrie prächtig
entwickeln können also andere wollen
einen fortress europe also
handelsschranken nach außen und ja das
land was am meisten verlieren würde
das sind wir ich was ich vermisst habe
in dieser debatte ist die wirkliche
hauptfrage im moment die sich stellt im
zusammenhang mit dem exit können wir
nicht europa eventuell so verändern dass
die briten dann doch noch drin bleiben
ja es ist doch alles offen wo sind die
politiker die wirklich die europäische
einigung im sinn haben und alles
unternehmen um die briten einzuholen so
dass sie mit erhobenem haupte jedenfalls
ihre entscheidung revidieren können
nehmen wir mal was was cameron wollte
cameron wollte ja eine verzögerte
integration der sozialen migranten in
das britische sozialsystem gesagt die
kommen jetzt alle ob zu recht oder nicht
also jedenfalls kommen sie und sie
müssen bezahlt werden
und das kann der sozialstaat nicht
leisten sozial magnetismus war sein
großes thema man hat ihn abblitzen
lassen mit seiner forderung diese
integration verzögert vorzunehmen aber
viele menschen in europa empfinden es
und als ökonom kann ich sagen sie haben
sogar recht dass da was nicht in ordnung
ist es ist ja richtig wenn die menschen
wandern von a nach b weil der lohn höher
ist aber wenn sie waren dann auch
deswegen weil sie da mehr
sozialleistungen kriegen das ist nicht
in ordnung dieser typ von wanderungen
der nützt überhaupt niemanden der ist
falsch und daran kann auch schaden
nehmen
ja es nimmt schaden es hat schon schaden
genommen wie wir es am drechselt ja
sehen und die konsequenz müsste jetzt
seien wirklich mal europa so zu
reformieren dass es besser wird das ist
gut für uns und es würde den briten ein
angebot machen wir könnten den briten
ein angebot machen dass sich noch mehr
ablehnen können und in letzter minute
konnte das unglück des britischen
austritt vielleicht noch verhindert und
ich spreche jetzt einfach mal als in der
europäische migrantin
das britische sozialsystem für elf jahre
genossen hat die briten haben zwei
entscheidungen getroffen sie haben
beschlossen die grenzen aufzumachen nach
der osterweiterung nur die briten die
ihren ich glaube die schweden gemacht
und die briten haben sehr großzügige in
der tat sozialleistungen für migranten
wie milch oder wie jeden von ihnen der
vielleicht nach großbritannien ziehen
würde viel großzügiger als die deutschen
die deutschen haben durch nationale
gesetze die sozialleistungen für
zuwanderer aus der eu sehr viel stärke
geregelt ich glaube da muss man einfach
auch mal schauen wie die briten
sozusagen auf nationaler ebene hätten
vorgehen können und wollen einfach ein
relativ einfaches system das haben sie
auch in dem bereich gehabt und es ist ja
nur wenn man sich den deal anschaut den
der europäische rat kämen angeboten hat
im februar 2016 ganz viele punkte sind
sehr oft david kammern eingegangen so
weit wie im vertrag möglich war
inklusive dem kidman dass man im
folgenden parlament die soziale fragen
die sozialleistungen für migranten neu
überdenken und eventuell gesetzgeberisch
angehen würde
also ich denke dass die briten auf
nationaler ebene viel hätten menschliche
gar nicht selber vorher fehler gemacht
sie können es nicht alles der eu ist zu
schieben aber es ist wie es ist diese
sozialen migration war das große thema
und cameron hat sich bitter darüber
beklagt dass er keine unterstützung fand
in der eu machte saadi gehen so linsler
hat das thema denn ernst genommen und
jetzt wollen sie rausgehen und ist ein
unglück weil es die zweitgrößte
volkswirtschaft ist unser größter
exportmarkt war hat das ist schwierig
ist das dorf geblieben das ist klar ein
anderes wird also das ist das große
thema projekt sind über das wäre
wirklich ja auch ganz viel gesprochen
haben wir werden jetzt wird er gerne mal
ein bisschen nach vorne schauen
bei dem anderen thema was so großes
thema ist die migration
das wurde eben auch groß angesprochen
ein thema wo sich die eu eben überhaupt
nicht einig ist herr könig was war ihr
eindruck wie darüber gesprochen wurde
und wo der haben sie den eindruck dass
je nachdem wer kommissionspräsident wird
oder wie sich eine neue kommission
einstellt dass es da
einigkeit geben kann in der u oder wird
es noch stärker an er war zum thema
migration enttäuschend der höhepunkt der
migration unter flüchtlingswelle dabei
im herbst 2015 wir haben jetzt 2009/10
das sind vier jahre oder dreieinhalb
jahre und immer noch hat man keine
lösung keine gemeinsame lösung immer
noch debattiert man man muss ja und wir
brauchen pläne und so weiter das ist
enttäuschend
und da habe ich eigentlich von keinem
der kandidaten irgend etwas brauchbares
gehört das heißt grenzen sicher frontex
stärken all das aber dass das leben viel
zeit geht langsam weiter
ja und das für uns gehört natürlich
viele leute ich möchte ich möchte
vorausschicken ich finde dass europa
noch nie in der geschichte der
menschheit einen so guten zustand hat
wie jetzt ich will nicht jetzt werden
nur kritiker dastehen aber es könnte
sehr vieles im rahmen der europäischen
union sehr viel besser sein
das ist immer mehr nach afrika geschaut
werden es wurde ja gefordert
ein kommissar für afrika bonse wäre das
sinnvoll hatte weber gesagt sollte ein
kommissar geben der sich kommt er mit
afrika bestehe also das ist für meine
begriffe reine symbolpolitik ich weiß
auch nicht was dieser kommissar
eigentlich tun soll
wer wird sich auch gedanken ja man wird
sich bedanken und wir hatten vor zehn
jahren vielleicht erinnert sich der eine
oder andere noch mal in diese diskussion
aus frankreich angestoßen um eine
mittelmeer-union das wurde alles in
berlin in bausch und bogen verdammt
afrika überhaupt nicht interessant
jetzt ist es plötzlich die priorität
nummer eins und da muss ich auch den
schon teilweise viel gelobten herrn
ebert dann mal ein bisschen doch hier
unter beschuss nehmen sage jetzt mal
doch ein wenig und also wenn er jetzt
verspricht er macht ein afrika kommissar
und er will also innerhalb von drei
jahren frontex aufstocken auf 10.000
beamte dann hat er ein
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem und zwar in
seiner eigenen partei
denn der innenminister heißt horst
seehofer ein parteifreund von herrn
weber und horst seehofer hat in brüssel
in verschiedenen minister ratssitzung
selber erklärt das ist nicht möglich vor
2025 so schnell aufzustocken auch
deutschland kann nicht so viele
grenzbeamte nach griechenland
sonst für den schicken das geht einfach
gar nicht und es macht keinen sinn jetzt
im wahlkampf dinge zu behaupten die die
kommission behauptet hatte die
kommission wollte 2020 die eu hat jetzt
beschlossen die minister 2027 jetzt zu
sagen 2022 muss es sein also da ist in
der tat ein glaubwürdigkeitsproblem und
letzten endes hat keiner der kandidaten
die wollte gehört haben eine antwort auf
die migrations die haus herausforderung
betrachtet richtig sein er hat ja gesagt
immerhin dass uns macht sie sagen es ist
unrealistisch dass es so schnell kommt
ja gut aber was er will ist ja richtig
dass finden sie auch richtig wir müssen
doch frontex stärken wir brauchen eine
europäische migrationspolitik einigkeit
wenn ich dinge versprechen die wir nicht
umsetzen können haben denn selbst der
bundesinnenminister sagt er kann das
nicht umsetzen in dieser zeit also man
muss dann realistische versprechungen
machen ja wann fängt besser mal mit den
visionen an nicht und dann kommt die
realität hinterher
das kommt auch keine gemeinsame vision
europa was mal so zu doch glaube ich
schon ja ich glaube schon dass ist dass
letztlich alle länder dafür sind dass
man ein einheitliches asylsystem hat und
die außengrenzen irgendwie kontrolliert
sodass die das klar ist nach welchen
regeln die wirklich bedürftigen und
verfolgten dann rein können also das ist
es nur das problem ist kostet geld
wer gibt jetzt wie viel und so weiter an
den laien die kranken wurde aber vom
grundsatz wollen sie das doch alle nur
das sieht man mal wieder europa ist
nicht in der lage zu entscheiden und das
wurde ja vorhin schon gesagt wir
brauchen also in manchen bereichen mehr
mehr einstimmigkeit ich bin nicht für
bei um verteilungsfragen da nicht wo es
also geld und geld geht dass sie in
einen weggenommen und dem anderen
gegeben wird das kann man also nicht mit
mir mit mehrheit machen aber hier muss
es also eine klare linie geben und da
dürfen nicht minderheiten blockieren
können
aber was wenn sie sagen wie sollte man
da welche möglichkeiten gibt es in der
migrationspolitik wirklich nach vorne zu
gucken jetzt nach den europawahlen
chance gibt's da das war schwach in der
debatte aber das war in seiner freiheit
realistisch denn weder die kommission
noch das parlament bestimmen die
europäische migrationspolitik die
europäische union hat sehr wenige
kompetenzen im bereich migration
grenzsicherung ist eine der wenigen
kompetenzen und und die auf die sich
auch die länder einigen können in
gewisser weise hat es also realistisch
und den herrn die daten daher keine ich
bin bin ich eine ich bin mir in keinster
weise sicher dass die europäischen
länder sich einig darüber sind wie ein
europäisches asylsystem aussehen sollte
ich denke was interessant werden wird
ist wir werden ja ganz starken
rechtspopulistisch euro-skeptischen
block im parlament sehen in fragen von
migration sagen in der grundfrage sind
sich die rechtspopulisten einig was aber
konkret passieren soll nicht mehr
anschauen
die italiener möchten zum beispiel wenn
ich mir anschaue was die deutschen
populisten möchten das aber diametral
gegen entgegengesetzt und ich denke da
müssen wirklich da müssen die da müssen
die mitglieds mitgliedstaaten und
gemeinsam handeln meist natürlich
rechtspopulisten geschafft haben ist
dass alle parteien in gewisser weise in
nach rechts gerückt sind in dieser frage
das wenige parteien mit ausnahme der
grünen wirklich offensiv noch für
migrations- und flüchtlingspolitik
eintreten aber wie sie sagen frau hätten
wir hatten eine direktive in der
umverteilung von flüchtlingen
beschlossen worden ist auf europäischer
ebene keine großen zahlen
trotzdem gelingt es der eu nicht diese
direktive umzusetzen
obwohl der von ganz kleiner schritt war
da ist ja auch keine einigung das ist
auch nicht sinnvoll glaube ich aber eher
sinnvoll ist es die grenzen zu schützen
und dann die wenigen die die dann
reinkommen na gut aber man muss mein
vater in brüssel läuft nicht so sehr um
die frage grenzen schützen ja oder nein
das sagen bekommen tatsächlich halle die
läufen soll das eine zentrale kompetenz
seien in brüssel oder leib das doch
internationale verantwortung wird
sozusagen der grenzschutz europäisiert
das wollen also zum teil die italiener
nicht die ungeraden wollen ist von gar
nicht in polen wollen es auch nicht und
das ist also eine debatte und dann ist
die andere debatte die damit verbunden
ist das ist in der tat auch die
reisefreiheit schengen
wir erleben jetzt von mal zu mal alle
halbe jahre werden die grenzkontrollen
die eigentlich gar nicht vorgesehen sind
immer wieder verlängert die
bundesregierung hat es gerade verlängert
frankreich das verlängert wir sind in
einem unhaltbaren zustand wo die grenzen
nicht richtig gesichert sind schenken
funktioniert nicht richtig mann handelt
sich alle halbe jahre rum und es kommen
keine dauerhaften geschenkt aber eben
nicht für migranten sondern nur eine
lust war
dabei geraten zuerst durch letzten drei
minuten haben etwas grundsätzliches zu
schauen ob diese europawahl und die
frage nach der zukunft
herr könig würden sie sagen das ist
jetzt eine chance weil das wurde ein ich
glaube ich noch nie so intensiv auch
über europa berichtet seitdem rexit sind
alle irgendwie alarmiert und haben das
gefühl wir müssen uns um dieses europa
kümmern wird von der schicksalswahl
gesprochen haben sie den eindruck dass
das nach dem 26 mai das ist dann
wirklich anders wird das europa- und
wären sie dafür dass wir sozusagen diese
vertiefung bekommen und mehr kompetenzen
für europa bekommen werde ich dafür aber
ich glaube auch dass die versuche in
diesem wahlkampf und mit solchen
terminen wie heute schon die richtige
richtung ist aber das darf nicht das das
ende sein also ich würde vorschlagen so
eine debatte in dieser form nicht zu
wiederholen die debatte mit den
kandidaten ein
dann muss man noch sehr viel üben und zu
lernen also nur nebenbei auch gesagt
diese zeitverschwendung wenn ich das so
sagen darf mit den sozialen medien dass
das ein paar tausend getwittert haben
oder fragen gestellt haben also wir
wollten hören was die kandidaten sagen
und nicht was getwittert werden das ja
das kann man ja damit wird er noch
nachlesen okay aber sie werden dafür
dass man eben mehr europa mehr konnten
sie europa eine der gefahren die sich
bei dich bitte schicksalswahl
es werden ein polarisiertes und
fragmentierte europäisches parlament
bekommen in der praxis wird das heißen
dass wir bei allen fragen der besetzung
von ämtern und dass wir im
gesetzgebungsverfahren super große
koalition haben werden und zwar aus der
svp fraktion von herrn weber den
sozialdemokraten für einen timmermanns
den liberalen wenn das reicht potenzial
noch den grünen sagen super große
koalition um überhaupt gesetze zu
verabschieden
was wir aber haben sind zwei gruppen die
an den rändern weniger europa wollen
aber auch mehr europa wollen und ich
glaube keiner dieser gruppen weder die
mobilisierten jungen leute die mehr
europa wollen noch die mobilisierten
leute die sich für mehr europa fürchten
werden bedient werden der kommenden
legislaturperiode also diese frage der
doppelten enthüllung die chance für zeit
ganz kurz mehr europa weniger tage
mehrere winter ich bin für mehr europa
bei der verteidigung bei der
grenzsicherung bei grenzüberschreitenden
verkehrswegen bei wirklichen
europäischen aufgaben und für weniger
europawahl umverteilungs wasna okay gut
ich würde sagen wir brauchen mehr
demokratie in europa also mehr debatte
vor allem aber auch der streit und nicht
nur fragen eine antwort runden wie diese
heute abend das waren nice nice zu
helfen guter guter versuch sozusagen
aber bereich mehr kontroverse und auch
wirkliche wahl wolle richtung und jene
richtung und wieder sicher in brüssel
witz und der wirt kommissionspräsident
möglicherweise jemand der da schon mal
gearbeitet hat möglicherweise japan je
oder frau westerwelle
ok ja ich bin gespannt und vielen dank
für die debatten die wir natürlich noch
fortführen morgen gibt's wieder eine
phoenix runde dann schauen wir in den
iran usa contra iran eskaliert der
konflikt fragen wir
und bei phoenix geht natürlich jetzt
weiter wie sie das canon mit für nix der
tag und stephan kulle moderiert schönen
abend
[Musik]